hey this is sort of strange uh Donald
Trump spoke at Sacred Heart University
in Connecticut over the weekend and he
said to the audience hey I might
actually lie to you he turned to the
audience and pointed to a high-school
kid that he introduced who's fighting
cancer and said that he wouldn't lie to
the kid whose name is Giacomo Brancato
he said I wouldn't lie to the kid who's
fighting cancer but to all you people I
might actually lie this was a very
strange speech that went on for about an
hour it was long it was rambling it had
no direction no common sense just a very
very strange strange speech and Trump
sort of capping it the cherry on top of
the speech is telling the crowd I might
just lie to all you people everybody but
this one kid next to me I might be lying
too it was very weird and I'll play it
for you
this is 100% certain okay I'm telling
this to Giacomo right I might lie to you
like Hillary does all the time but I'll
never lie to Giacomo okay yeah
all right Giacomo you helped me to it
we're gonna build the wall but
whoo-hoo-hoo he's gonna pay for the wall
now funniest thing is that immediately
after saying he wouldn't lie to Giacomo
but he would lie to the audience maybe
he told a lie which is that Mexico is
gonna pay for that wall there's no
chance in hell Louis that Mexico is
paying for that wall which will likely
not even be built but there he
immediately lied to the audience I guess
it's good that he's finally being honest
and saying I might lie to you
here's lie number one immediately after
it's it's good yes he's admitting that
he's a liar but in Donald Trump's
defense Dave yeah we're a bit The
Devil's in the details area
he never said Mexico is gonna pay for a
wall all he said was who is going to pay
for the wall and the audience said it
was Mexico right he told the lie but he
said 100 right jáchym oh when he said
we're gonna build the wall cuz he knows
it's not gonna happen
everything about this campaign is nuts
this particular rally Trump showed up a
half-hour late no air conditioning in
the building remember how hot it was
this weekend in the Northeast bunch of
people had to be treated for heat
related symptoms Trump rambles aimlessly
for more than an hour before telling the
crowd that he might lie to them if there
were to be a documentary made about the
Trump campaign I might be lying to you
would be a really good title I could see
like an independent Netflix style
documentary called I might be lying to
you and it's all about the Trump
campaign yeah I might be lying to you or
or this I will tell you and maybe just
terrific remember the good old days when
MIT Romney seemed like sort of a
run-of-the-mill out-of-step social
conservative I would love to go back to
those days before before the Republican
nominee was truly evidence that a
significant portion of this country has
has descended into total insanity Mitt
Romney was just a normal guy and he
looks great right now yeah he's just
you're you like you said run-of-the-mill
Republican uh nothing uh the major
donors big corporations or uh Joe the
Plumber type guys had to worry about you
know what is actually great about Trump
going up on stage and saying I might lie
to you PolitiFact a value evaluated that
statement and they've determined it's
100% true this is the first time
PolitiFact has ever said something Trump
said is actually true usually it's like
a partially untrue pants on fire total I
try
saying to the audience he might lie to
them finally is actually a true
statement according to PolitiFact I did
great work done by PolitiFact I don't
think I needed them to know that that
was accurate but thank you
what's Trump even doing in Connecticut
anyway I mean there there's a poll where
Trump is only like five or six points
behind Hillary in Connecticut say that I
was in Connecticut that that's with
seventeen percent of respondents saying
they don't yet know who they're going to
vote for it it seems like a total waste
of time for Trump or you can completely
forsake any state uh
regardless of what the numbers look like
there if uh that's that's good
campaigning really I'd love to see Trump
here in Massachusetts great use of time
that would be that that would be an
interesting when it actually would be
great cuz we could show up an interview
Trump supporters send me your thoughts
on this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
we have such a great show for you today
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed dot-com slash TDP s I don't
really like going into glasses stores
and trying on glasses well the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com slash TDP s it costs nothing